er sollte sich niemals wiederholen weder
in den usa noch in den ländern ihrer
verbündeten dafür waren sie in den krieg
gezogen gegen den terrorismus allein in
afghanistan forderte dieser krieg
unzählige verletzte mehr als dreieinhalb
tausend tote bei amerikanischen und
alliierten streitkräften osama bin laden
ist ausgeschaltet für us-präsident
beiden ist die mission damit erfüllt
welche interessen haben wir dann doch
nachdem al kaida nun weg ist
als sei es in wirklichkeit gar nicht um
mehr gegangen aber al qaida existiert
immer noch ist nicht besiegt trotzdem
behauptet die us regierung auch jede
künftige terrorgefahr im griff zu haben
aus der ferne
zeiten an die löwen sind unsere
fähigkeit mit terrorismus auch da fertig
zu werden wo wir keine soldaten haben
die mensch gewachsen wir können jetzt
dinge tun die vor 20 jahren nicht
möglich waren wenn die gefahren
afghanistan wieder auftaucht werden wir
damit fertig
meint michael nagata ehemaliger general
bei den spezialkräften danach
stellvertretender leiter des anti terror
zentrums der us regierung terroristen
aus der ferne stoppen reines
wunschdenken man kann sie unter druck
setzen auch stören aber man kann sie
nicht strategisch besiegen und sicher
auch nicht vollständig vernichten es ist
zu weit weg
der anti terrorkampf das weiß nagata aus
30 jähriger erfahrung braucht mehr um
die richtigen ziele auszuschalten und
terrorpläne dauerhaft zu veralten
gezielte drohnen einsätze sind nur mit
stationierungen innerhalb der regionen
möglich angriffe nur dann erfolgreich
wenn es menschliche quellen vor ort gibt
die verlässliche informationen
wenn wir uns entscheiden nichts zu tun
außer anti terror operationen aus der
ferne erhöht die ist das risiko bei
unseren einsätzen so sehr dass nach
einer weile auch schwere niederlagen
unvermeidlich sind
die größte gefahr in der region geht vom
sk aus dem ableger des esc in
afghanistan er verfügt über rund 800
kämpfer sieht sich als feind der taliban
und propagiert den globalen terrorismus
ein weltweites terrornetz hat auch al
qaida seine filialen von mali bis
bangladesch feiern den abzug der
alliierten als großen sieg die 600 al
kaida kämpfer in afghanistan sind eng
verzahnt mit den taliban in ihrem jubel
pamphleten verbreiten sie eine eigene
neue titel version eines alten time
-magazins hier die parodie und dies das
original von 2001
ob sie eine massive clevere
komplizierter attacke für üben können
weiß ich nicht aber ich kenne beide
organisationen gut genug wenn sie die
gelegenheit bekommen werden sie die
fähigkeit dafür entwickeln
deshalb so meinte nagata müsse der
westen von den taliban fordern dass sie
terror gruppen keinen schutz geben
helfen soll dabei pakistan wir treffen
den pakistanischen botschafter in
washington seine regierung steht unter
dem verdacht den kampf der taliban gegen
die afghanische armee
mitfinanziert zu haben das bestreitet
assad kann er verspricht unterstützung
im vorgehen gegen terrorgruppen
wir haben eine beziehung zu den taliban
aber wir kontrollieren und finanzieren
sie nicht sie sind nicht auf unserer
gehaltsliste
und wir werden mit dem westen und
anderen ländern weiter zusammenarbeiten
weil wir von denselben terrorgruppen
bedroht werden wie sie
botschafter kann hält die taliban für
kompromissbereit sie stünden unter
erfolgsdruck den menschen in afghanistan
bessere perspektiven zu bieten als die
bisherige regierung
die signale aus afghanistan insbesondere
kabul sind positiv
die taliban scheinen zuzuhören
sensibilisiert zu sein gegenüber den
bedenken der internationalen
gemeinschaft
gerade auf dem weg hierher sah ich ein
video das vom taliban-sprecher
veröffentlicht wurde mit mädchen die in
kabul zur schule gehen
aber dass man der taliban propaganda
nicht trauen kann das müsste die
pakistanische regierung aus eigener
erfahrung wissen
2011 besuchten wir das swat tal im
norden pakistans
hier ließ die regierung 2009 eine
machtergreifung der taliban zu 80.000
pakistanische soldaten mussten das tal
hinterher befreit mit scharia gerichten
und öffentlichen hinrichtungen so
erzählte uns general kadir hatten die
taliban die menschen zu helfen ihres
schreckens regimes gemacht kadir zeigte
uns dass um erziehungs lager für die
taliban mitläufer
gleichzeitig aber duldet die
pakistanische regierung den geistlichen
rat der taliban die quetta schura in der
gleichnamigen stadt unserer kollegin zu
hat mehr kennen erzählte einer der
anführer sie würden bei einer
machtübernahme zwar mädchenschulen
erlauben aber bei der scharia dem
islamischen gesetz werde es keine
kompromisse geben
trotzdem hält botschafter kann die
taliban für besser als die bisherige wie
er sagt korrupte regierung afghanistan
wir fragen ihn warum pakistans
premierminister imran khan kurz nach dem
fall von kabul davon sprach afghanistan
habe die ketten der sklaverei zerbrochen
ich möchte ihre aufmerksamkeit auf
mindestens 200 statements lenken die
unser premierminister nicht nur kürzlich
sondern in den letzten 20 jahren
abgegeben hat dabei hat er immer für
eine nicht militärische lösung des
konflikts in afghanistan plädiert
und pakistan hat tatsächlich immer
wieder alle afghanischen gruppen
unterstützt und ermutigt miteinander zu
reden
nun reden die taliban auch mit ex
präsident hamid karzai und früheren
regierungsmitgliedern aber eine
einheitsregierung die menschen- und
frauenrechte garantiert die
terrorgruppen keine zuflucht gewährt
kaum vorstellbar deshalb könnte sich der
terror doch wiederholen in den usa und
in den ländern ihrer verbündeten